bonjour à tous et à toutes et joyeuses
fêtes et oui on n'a pas résisté à vous
faire un petit épisode de noël
entre nous c'est surtout parce que toute
l'équipe adore porter des bonnets
ridicule on a concocté un épisode qui
devrait vous plaire surtout à toi benoît
oui toi benoît qui partage beaucoup nos
vidéos et qui travaillent à la
production dans certains vins pétillants
alors non non je ne vais pas vous faire
un épisode sur la science des bulles de
champagne
on a déjà assez parlé de bulles dans
l'épisode sur la mousse de la bière vous
vous souvenez non aujourd'hui on
débouche le champagne et on fait des
panaches bleus cette vidéo a été tournée
à huit mille images par seconde par
l'équipe effervescence de l'université
de reims lorsque le bouchon est éjecté
un étrange panache azur est visible au
niveau du goulot
ne vous jetez pas sur vos bouteilles de
champagne pour tester d'une part le
phénomène se déroule dans les deux
premières milices secondes de
l'ouverture et d'autre part il faut que
votre bouteille soit à plus de 12 degrés
pas idéal pour un champagne d'un point
de vue purement chimiques le champagne
est simplement une solution
hydroalcoolique cantonnant du dioxyde de
carbone dissous formé pendant la phase
appelée prise de mousse par les
connaisseurs on a de l'eau de l'alcool
et des bulles quoi éveiller molécules
qui donne du bon hockey
lorsqu'on ouvre une bouteille de
champagne le petit nuage de gaz présents
dans le goulot du co2 et quelques traces
de vapeur d'eau va sortir et se dilater
ce gaz carbonique qui étaient soumis à
une très forte pression va passer à la
pression de l'air ambiant en moins de
3000 secondes
cette diminution brutale de la pression
du co2 entraînent une diminution tout
aussi brutale de sa température
on va voir deux cas de figure sur ces
images la bouteille a été conservé à une
température inférieure à 12 degrés on
peut voir un petit nuage blanc gris qui
correspond à la condensation de la
vapeur d'eau naturellement présentes
dans l'air autour de la bouteille comme
les nuages dans le ciel sur ses autres
images on voit l'ouverture d'une
bouteille qui elle est conservée à 20
degrés et là pas de nuages blancs mais
en étonnant panache bleu bien verticale
les chercheurs ont déterminé que ce
panache bleu est dû en fait un nuage de
microparticules de neige carbonique qui
va diffuser la lumière
et ouais c'est du sérieux de congé dans
votre bouteille de champagne
pourtant le co2 ne se congèle cas moins
son 18 degrés ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'à l'ouverture de cette bouteille la
température du gaz va chuter de plus de
100 degrés en l'espace de trois minutes
secondes atteignant jusqu'à -80 8 degrés
le point de congélation du co2 est alors
franchi et de minuscules cristaux de
glace carbonique vont alors se former
sans passer par la phase liquide et ce
sont ces minuscules cristaux de glace
carbonique qui sont responsables de la
couleur bleue du panache le bleu du ciel
est dû au même phénomène s'appelle
diffusion de réelles mais pourquoi le
panache bleu ne se forme qu'avec une
bouteille qui est conservé à une
température de plus de 12 degrés plus la
bouteille est chaude plus il ya de co2
sous forme de gaz dans le boulot et
moins il ya de co2 dans le liquide
exactement comme quand on laisse une
bouteille de soda en dehors du frigo la
pression du gaz dans le goulot de cette
bouteille et donc plus grande au départ
et à l'ouverture
la décompression va donc être plus forte
et la chute de température plus
importante
et paf ça fait des micros glaçons de co2
allez c'est cadeau
voilà à quoi ressemble le g2 liquide au
moment de l'ouverture d'une bouteille
filmé à huit mille images par seconde
[Musique]
pourquoi cette couleur cuivrée et bien
tout simplement parce que pour cette
étude publiée dans la revue nature
d'ailleurs les chercheurs ont utilisé
des bouteilles transparentes de
champagne rosé
bord de mon côté je vais mettre les
bouteilles bien au frais en attendant le
nouvel an je vous souhaite de très
bonnes fêtes de fin d'année comme le co2
décompresser